last weekend sentinel's valorant player
Hunter sick Mims was arrested for
criminal trespassing after tweeting out
a video of what appeared to be him
getting into an altercation at a Ferrari
dealership as a publication sick remains
in jail since his arrest many including
Sentinel CEO Rob Moore have called for
the community to support sick during
this time it's a complicated story so
let's lay out everything we know
okay so after speaking with the Collin
County Detention Facility and Consulting
six inmate entry form I can confirm that
sick was arrested on Saturday March 4th
for a Class B misdemeanor charge of
criminal trespassing I contacted the
dealership this incident allegedly
occurred at and they declined to comment
sick has been held at the Collin County
Jail in McKinney Texas for the past
seven days while he awaits trial his
bond is at five thousand dollars and has
not been paid in Texas a criminal
trespassing charge can result in a fine
of up to two thousand dollars in jail
time of up to 180 days on March 3rd sick
uploaded a video of himself getting into
an altercation at what some of alleged
is a Ferrari dealership in Plano Texas
in the video sick is asked to leave the
premises or else police would be called
he refuses and the video ends before his
arrest sick was the sixth man on
sentinel's Valiant roster he was
suspended from Sentinels on March 6th
and they are currently searching for
another player to replace him okay so
that's how we got here but to better
understand the entire situation we need
to go over the timeline of events sick
was Bench from Sentinels towards the end
of May 2022 due to what a team referred
to as a family matter on June 20th he
explained that he was dealing with
mental health problems then in October
Sig was brought back as a sixth man for
the roster but he hasn't played with the
team since his initial break back in May
during sentinel's VCT lock-in game
against fnatic on February 24th of this
year sick tweeted out that he was not
allowed into the arena and felt
disrespected by Riot games he continued
to tweet about not getting let into the
venue throughout the day and
specifically called out sentinel's
Twitter account sick tweeted out a
picture of the old Sentinels roster
which some fans interpreted as a jab
against the team's current lineup since
they were swept by fnatic that day
Joelle Nagy who is married to Rory deaf
Jackson sentinel's current igl tweeted
about Esports players spouting
egocentric nonsense sick took this as a
direct call out and responded to her
many of those tweets have since been
deleted sick later took to his twitch
stream and explained that death
confronted him in the Sentinels Discord
server though then death he says in the
group chat he says something like bro
don't talk to about my wife like this
bro like bro like what are you doing bro
like what is this bro and I'm like you
guys are not good people no one is
respecting my opinion no one has seen my
position they aren't understanding me
and these are people I know well I know
death very well two years I've known
this man he's good man to me but I don't
know what's going on with him maybe he's
upset about the loss whatever bro on the
26th of February 6th then girlfriend
kasube accused sick of being unfaithful
having police remove her from their home
an alleged that sick did something to
make kaide who is engaged to his
teammate tens uncomfortable this
culminated in sick eventually going live
on Twitch on February 27th to address
the situations he denied doing anything
to intentionally make Kai day
uncomfortable and also claimed that he'd
never been happier in his entire life he
also added that he didn't believe it was
safe for him to be around his ax and
said that he felt disrespected by
everyone around him including Sentinels
oh I'll explain exactly what happened
because I feel very disrespected in some
of these situations it's not about it's
not about my girlfriend it's not about
that bro like he's okay she's safe like
everyone's safe like I have nothing
against anyone in this situation I just
feel disrespected in some ways and I'll
explain but we're at the event
I feel very disrespected by the team
I'll be honest bro like the the you know
the two days leading up to the match I
can't be with them like like I said it's
okay I'm not reasonable about this like
I'm having a good time with my friends
but then I try on Match day I'm like in
the morning I talk to my manager I talk
to my player I handle like my guys I'm
gonna come with my friends to the event
I show up I talk to the first person in
charge the second the third nothing can
be done bro so you know what I do is I I
talk about it I feel very disrespected
with my time just like I'm talking to
you guys I want you to respect my time
while I expect yours many in the
community commented on six tweets and
his recent streams including Kai day
herself I shouldn't is All I'm gonna say
right now I don't think it is in
um either of our interests to
really talk about it when
I'm sure you guys can see sick is not
doing well and I'm not gonna kick
someone down when they're not doing well
and uh I I think you guys will
understand the whole scope once
everything is properly explained on a
stream on March 2nd six said that he
bought a Ferrari and added that family
members were contacting him concerned
about his mental health and I have my
own family member man calling me asking
me if I'm schizophrenic telling me she's
going to call someone to help me saying
that I can't afford this car have you
lost your mind I had to block them never
again they're not my people wow bad
person yell at Bitter I don't know what
it is but I don't care bro it's pretty
sad and on March 3rd sick posted a video
to Twitter which according to reporting
by dot Esports George Gettys shows him
arguing with an off-camera Ferrari
dealership employee who threatens to
call the police if sick does not leave
the premises get out of my office okay
bye
get out of the store
many in the community were concerned
about the video posted and six former
teammate Shazam responded by asking sick
to answer his phone calls sick was
arrested on March 4th and has not
tweeted since though many of his streams
and tweets leading up to the arrest have
since been deleted on March 8th Sentinel
CEO Rob Moore commented on the situation
in a Twitter statement saying this
Sentinels has always been committed to
supporting our players through any
hardships they may face this has been no
different with Hunter our goal is to
support Hunter during this difficult
moment Moore also confirmed that
Sentinels are looking for a sixth player
to replace sick during this time in
response to the Tweet many accuse the
organization of not doing enough to help
sick before the events that led to his
arrest however kasubi defended the org
stating that they have been supporting
his well-being throughout the entire
situation
oh